Most of us strive to lose weight,
but these people might be actively trying to gain it.
might be actively trying to gain it.
If they continue to eat this much food,
they could end up weighing up to
Now, gaining 5 to 10 lb (2.26 to 4.5 kg)
during the holidays is one thing,
but gaining 300 lb (136 kg)
usually happens gradually,
after years of bad habits
combined with other factors.
But how about we speed up that process
and have you gain 300 lb (136 kg) in just one year?
in just one year?
What kind of health problems
could you expect?
Rapid weight gain is when you put on
a large amount of weight in a short time.
And that's what we'll be doing today.
Most people would find it a challenge
to gain 100 lb (45 kg) in a year.
But we'll be gaining 300 lb (136 kg).
Could it be eating a mountain
of McDonald's every day?
Canceling your gym membership?
Or both?
Let's find out.
So you're trying to gain 300 lb in a year.
That breaks down to
25 lb (11 kg) a month.
There are many factors
that contribute to rapid weight gain.
Let's start with an obvious one, diet.
One study concluded
that eating 1,000 extra calories a day
for five days
did not lead to significant weight gain.
However,
eating 1,000 extra calories a day
for a month
led to a weight gain
of about 3 lb (1.36 kg)
and increased blood sugar.
That's like eating seven or eight
Big Macs a day for 30 days.
But those are rookie numbers.
To reach your goal
of gaining 25 lb (11.3 kg) a month,
you would need to quintuple
that amount of calories.
Wow. That's a lot of Big Macs.
By now, you've gained 25 lb (11.3 kg).
In addition to eating thousands
and thousands of calories
of junk food,
you’ve also incorporated
a second element
into your weight gain journey.
And that's eliminating exercise.
You won't even be able to walk,
as that expends too many calories
for this challenge.
You may feel a little sluggish,
but the extra weight
hasn't affected you too much, yet.
Now you've gained 75 lb (34 kg).
You've begun to notice it,
both in how you feel and look.
A third and unexpected
contributor to weight gain
is lack of sleep.
We burn calories while we sleep.
So to stay on track with our weight gain,
you're going to need to sleep
the bare minimum a human needs.
Leading you to feel
more and more exhausted.
Now you're feeling it.
With 150 extra pounds (68 kg),
how could you not?
You're tired all the time.
You don't recognize yourself.
And you're on the path
to some serious health problems.
You know, a fourth element
that plays a role in rapid weight gain
is genetics.
If you want to complete
this challenge in time,
your genetics will have to be pretty bad.
At least when it comes
to keeping your weight off.
According to
the Harvard Medical School,
more than 400 different genes
can contribute to obesity.
These genes can affect things like
appetite, metabolism, and feeling full.
So not only are you always craving
large quantities of food
that are high in trans fats,
carbs, and sugar,
but your stomach is a bottomless pit
and your metabolism can't keep up.
Over 12 months, you managed
to combine all the factors,
eating tons of junk food, not exercising,
not sleeping enough
and bad genetics.
And you met your 300 lb (136 kg) goal.
Now what?
Well, putting on that much weight
would make it hard to move or walk.
Your bones would have
trouble supporting you.
You'd likely be diagnosed
with some significant health problems
like heart disease, diabetes, or cancer.
Even breathing can become difficult.
Plus, obesity is linked
to depression and low self-esteem.
So you'd not only be
physically unhealthy
but possibly mentally unhealthy as well.
That doesn't sound like
much of a life at all.
In general,
gaining a large amount of weight
in a short amount of time
is not a healthy or safe thing to do
and is therefore not worth it.
But if you want to gain weight
in a healthy way
by, say, using weight training
to build muscle slowly over time,
then yeah, give it a try.
But you won't gain 300 lb (136 kg)
in a year this way.
And that's a good thing.
You may be game to gain
300 lb (136 kg) in one year,
but we don't recommend it.
I think it's time to go on a health kick.
Let's try going vegan for a year.
Think you're up for it?
We'll see what the challenge brings
on another episode of